welcome to the secret headquarters of we  have searched the entire mountain and  that day has finally arrived  [Music]  calm down you know how you get it can't  be true  legal you will be banished from the  village until you are ready to tell us  the truth I know what I saw and I'm  gonna prove it is it too late to have  second thoughts if you die can I have  all your worldly possessions bleeding  right sorry when you die let's do this  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  is the first it's the house I'm taking  you home  [Music]  [Music]  we're gonna be safe here nice and warm  oh wait a minute what's how's that nice  and toasty all the way around hey what's  wrong  you hungry I found your food  [Music]  you  you